what's fair well Congress decided it was
seven dollars and twenty-five cents and
out why is it not seven dollars why is
enough $14 they're trying to decide
what's fair well in the original sense
of the word it was how you go about
earning your job that would be the rules
of fairness not what you actually earns
a wage I'm Bart Wilson on the dial peak
Kennedy professor of economics and law
at the economic science institute of
chapman university and by trade i'm an
experimental economist I'm somebody who
builds little worlds in the laboratory
and and recruits my undergraduates to
come participate in them for money and I
observed what they do and so instead of
building economic knowledge from first
principles I'm building it from
observation using control compounds the
laboratory to test and predict how
people behave people uses word fair a
lot and economist started using it a lot
in the 90s and I just think quite know
what they meant by it and but yet they
seem to know what they meant by it when
they said it I came across this linguist
on a vir spits go and she had done a
written whole chapter on the origins of
this word fair the word fair is an Anglo
concept in a sense that there's no one
to one translation of that word to any
other language other languages like
German will use the same word for just
as they do for fair and they might also
use similar as at for equitable in it
well that that's three two one so if
they have a same context in your German
you're going to just use that word but
in English we we won't use the word the
same a different context we might say it
doesn't feel right to use the word just
so one of the examples is that teachers
are considered to be fair or unfair you
don't complain about the teacher being
unjust that just doesn't quite work and
and so that fact that the words don't
quite work the same then means that we
use them to connote something very
particular fairs apply to situations in
which there
tacit rules governing your behavior and
that means there's a wide bounds which
you can make your decisions but then
there are some bounds that you can't
cross concept of fairness comes out of a
system of rules and and I think mostly
kind of tacit rules when you're talking
about personal social interactions much
more formal when you're talking about
baseball it's interesting that the
original antonym affair was not unfair
but follow and I think that brings out
what fair play is about so once I kinda
had this idea of what the kind of
current meaning meez and involves rules
and communities think about the problem
like did some further work of trying to
understand how this definition has
evolved I went to the first dictionary
of english language samuel johnson
published in 1755 and he listed the
definition of fairness as honesty candor
and Ingenuus pneus which is not how we
use it right now unfair as this Ingenuus
not honest or sub doulas which i didn't
know what it meant so i had to look that
up that me comes from the latin early
meeting under deceit again not how we
use the word today and what Samuel
Johnson is known for is giving really
good examples of the usage of the word
at the time and the example he cites
comes from Jonathan Swift in a letter to
his friend mr. Pope he says you come to
me like an unfair merchant to charge me
with being your debt so his prime
example of the word unfair involves
commerce emergent and it turns out
that's worth the word unfair was used
for generally in the 18th century was to
do business connections and business
relationships but what does it mean to
be a dishonest Richard means had these
scales
yes you know kind of to jip jip the
customer and so fairness meant what are
the rules of how you treat your
customers and it it's coming down to the
meat we're interested in how you go
about what you do when we apply the word
fair on fair I think public policy now
is kind of changed that meaning and the
meaning is come to the ends an example
is minimum wages so when Congress passed
the last minimum wage bill which I think
was 2007 it was called the fair minimum
wage act okay what's fair well Congress
decided it was seven dollars and
twenty-five cents an hour why is it not
seven dollars why is enough $14 they're
trying to decide what's fair well in the
original sense the word it was how you
go about earning your job that would be
the rules of fairness not what you
actually earns a wage I think for Public
Policy a lot of people are using the
word fair to look at the ends economists
tend to focus on equity when they talk
about fairness and one of my critiques
and is that we got to get away from that
fairness means a lot more than that than
just equity it's about the rules of the
game and and that's because fairness can
change from situation to situation and
so so the example a of the ultimatum
game in the ultimatum game one person is
designated as the proposer and is given
a set of money from the experimenter and
asked to decide how to divide that
between himself and another person once
the proposers made that decision would
say it's ten dollars decides to split it
six for himself or for the other person
the responder the second person decides
to accept or reject that offer if the
responder accepts the offer they take
their money and go home if responder
rejects the offer either gets anything
but robot will take anything anything is
greater you know one is better than
nothing so uh a robot would accept that
and another robot knowing that could
compute therefore I offer one
humans will see one dollar and be
offended by that and say no if you just
bring people in and randomly assign them
to be the proposers and the responders
the modal offers around half the pie fit
five dollars but if you first bring in
people and you give them a quiz and the
people who score best in the quiz get to
be the proposers the offers are much
lower and they're accepted the rejection
rates don't go up so people option what
is fair now is different and it's not
equal anymore so now the modal offer is
shifted down so fairness is still
involved but it's not equitable anymore
so if you earn the right people feel
more entitled to what they've been given
I think that's an important element that
when we put some of ourselves into what
we're doing we expect to have control
over it and other people expect to
expect you to do that and will respect
you for doing that what we find from
running experiments on fairness in the
laboratory is that our notion of it
varies pretty substantially depending on
the circumstances people are very
sensitive to this social context in
which they're making the decisions and
so our notions of what's fair can vary
pretty dramatically oh we don't work
towards a more fair Society consciously
we do it subconsciously and we do it all
the time in the sense of winter acting
with their friends family neighbors and
somebody goes outside the bounds of fair
play we say something when somebody asks
too much of somebody else we say you
can't do that and we do that all the
time we jointly as groups of individuals
decide what's good and proper for us and
that since it's a very local community
type concept the government shouldn't be
involved in that people are different
communities are different and government
doesn't know what
the standards are in different places
and different people so I think we do it
from the ground up
you